se han registrado protestas en contra de
esta medida le pregunto por qué tantos
salvadoreños desconfían de la cripto
moneda
buenos días roble gracias por la
invitación la verdad que el tema que el
salvador tiene dólares entonces al estar
organizado pues hace una economía
estable es una moneda estable una moneda
que tiene una relación directa con eeuu
un tercio de la población salvadoreña
vive en eeuu envía remesas familiares y
el problema del bitcoin es la
volatilidad entonces aparte del hecho de
ser digital y que la gente pues le tiene
temor al tema porque no está
acostumbrada a ella por un lado pero por
el otro lado la volatilidad le genera
desconfianza porque el dólar pues es muy
estable y entonces la gente se pregunta
el que voy a ganar con esto ahora
entonces no hay una expectativa de que
esto pueda generar un mayor crecimiento
económico que va a generar más empleo
sino que lo que puede generar es una vez
dolarización de la economía y eso lo que
más preocupa a la ciudadanía que tiene
dólares podría pasar a bitcoins pero
quiere terminar con dólares igual no
quiere quedarse con bitcoins por el
hecho de esa volatilidad que le puede
generar pérdidas o ganancias en
diferentes momentos
ahora louis cómo se pueden hacer estas
transferencias en línea sin pasar por
una institución financiera cómo funciona
esto
bueno el tema por ejemplo las remesas
familiares el tema es que la persona en
eeuu tendría que comprar un beat con lo
cual le genera costos porque siempre se
ha dicho aquí en el salvador que esto no
tendría ningún costo luego se pasaría la
billetera archivo que es la billetera
del gobierno y ahí se puede operar el
gobierno ha creado un fideicomiso de 150
millones de dólares con el que dice que
le daría convertibilidad todo bitcoin
que vengan a hizo a todo bit porque si
el culé en el país probablemente la masa
monetaria anda más o menos por 1.600
millones de dólares en el salvador y el
gobierno con 150 millones de dólares
pues no va a poder hacer mucho entonces
lo que
esperamos y prevemos es que el
fidecomiso se va a quedar sin dólares
muy rápidamente y como los bancos no son
los que van a hacer ninguna exención en
un intercambio de valor entre el bit
brain y el dólar entonces el problema y
el temor mayor es que esto sea una
política para desdolarizar y que
eventualmente se pueda crear una moneda
nacional de carácter digital ahora
hablemos de eso por qué ningún valor
material como el dinero convencional el
oro además de ser independiente de
cualquier gobierno o banco central que
la regule cuál es el respaldo que tiene
el bitcoin
pues no habría respaldo en la medida que
se crea esta billetera digital del
gobierno pues el gobierno regala 30
dólares por ejemplo que si fueran 2
millones de personas las que bajaron esa
aplicación estaría regalando 60 millones
de dólares entonces nada garantiza que
vaya a ver ese respaldo el gobierno dice
que ha comprado 400 veces los
equivalentes más o menos a 21 mil 22.000
dólares
perdón 21 millones 22 millones de
dólares en este momento entonces el
problema es que no hay un respaldo real
en bitcoins ni en dólares para esta
operación que está haciendo el gobierno
entonces eso es lo que genera la mayor
desconfianza y pues el gobierno ha
sostenido hasta este día que no va a
pagar los salarios por ejemplo las
pensiones y toda la realidad del
gobierno en bitcoins pero es el temor de
la población y la población rechaza han
habido personas que han llegado a la
asamblea legislativa a solicitar que se
pasen el link de que no se van a pagar
las pensiones que no se van a pagar los
salarios
pero obviamente el gobierno quiere
impulsarlo y la mejor forma de impulsar
lo va a hacer que ellos paguen todas sus
obligaciones a través de virtuales